allez on ouvre une petite page culture à
présent le théâtre Coluche de plaisir va
révéler sa prochaine saison culturelle
pour l'année 2023 2024 demain soir et
pour nous parler de la programmation la
directrice de la salle Florence Camoin
pour cette nouvelle saison culturelle
Florence camin vous avez sélectionné de
la danse des concerts des comédies ou
des pièces un petit peu plus dures parmi
elles ne m'a rien dit qui porte sur la
question des violences faites aux femmes
et du féminicide oui effectivement on
commence très très fort mais c'est un
sujet essentiel dans la brochure il est
dit que tous les deux jours et demi une
femme meurt sous les coups de son
compagnon et à qui m'a rencontré une
femme totalement extraordinaire j'ai eu
la chance de pas lui parler mais de la
voir et sur scène et de voir cette femme
lumineuse aghers ingère sahilie qui
a été malheureusement confronté à
l'assassinat de sa petite sœur qui était
handicapée et
[Musique]
donc c'était d'autant plus important de
soutenir cette création puisque c'est
une création en ce moment ils sont en
train de travailler de répéter donc je
ne l'ai pas vu j'ai vu des lectures j'ai
assisté à des démonstrations de
d'extrait de la pièce mais je n'ai pas
vu spectacle mais comme je connais un
autre spectacle dont on va peut-être
parler tout à l'heure je sais qu'elle a
un talent
justement donc il y a une autre pièce
qui fait réfléchir du même metteur en
scène c'est désaxé je vous propose de
regarder un extrait et on en parle juste
après
en France mon fils
[Musique]
ma vie c'est génial le mcdote le nutella
la Tour Eiffel un champs
ça fait deux mois qu'on est en France à
Aulnay-sous-Bois dans la cité des 3000
on va à l'école pour la première fois et
dans ma tête tout ça ça va pas durer
j'ai déjà mon école
et ça veut dire qu'on rentre pas chez
nous tout de suite maman
non mon fils va tout de suite
laissez maintenant comment ça marche le
premier qui me cherche
[Musique]
alors dans cette pièce on suit un
prisonnier qui écrit à ses parents
depuis la prison de Fleury-Mérogis il
retrace son parcours jusqu'à ce qu'il
devienne presque un djihadiste c'est une
pièce qui a l'air très saisissante elle
est très forte je l'ai découverte au
Festival d'Avignon et ça a été
je sais pas c'est un coup de poing qu'on
se prend dans la figure parce que en
fait on se pose pas forcément on a vu le
Bataclan on a vu plein de choses on a
été on a eu des amis qui ont été
victimes mais on sait pas en fait tout
ce qui se cache derrière et comment se
font les recrutements et comment
certains jeunes sont happés et d'autres
arrivent à s'en sortir et donc c'est
voilà c'est encore une histoire qui
nécessite qu'on en parle qu'on en parle
aux jeunes qui a un témoignage et que
qu'on apprenne aux jeunes surtout aux
jeunes je pense beaucoup à eux à
réfléchir par eux-mêmes et pas se
laisser embrigader par les adultes qui
n'ont pas forcément toujours les bonnes
réponses et c'est une pièce quasi
autobiographique parce que c'est arrivé
à Kim Jaziri donc il sait de quoi il
parle et il sait comment il s'en est
sortis donc c'est passionnant fascinant
bon après avoir parlé de deux pièces un
peu sérieuses un peu dur je vous propose
de parler de comédie parce que dans
votre programmation vous avez laissé une
grande place à l'humour tout de même
notamment avec cette pièce une idée
géniale qui a reçu deux Molières
exactement et je l'ai programmé avant de
le savoir
et alors de quoi on parle dans cette
pièce c'est une histoire de Sosie c'est
la deuxième pièce de Sébastien Castro il
a déjà eu je crois le Molière de la
meilleure comédie pour la précédente et
en fait
il a des sosie et donc il joue tous les
sosies évidemment et et les autres
rencontrent les différences sosies et se
perdent dans ces sosies parce qu'ils
savent jamais lequel est le bon et
lui-même ne sait pas qui il est
finalement mais c'est impossible à
raconter mais c'est 30 oui c'est un rire
toutes les 30 secondes quoi c'est
complètement délirant il y a
c'est les deux grandes l'humour
actuellement en France donc voilà c'est
pour passer le moment de un moment de
pure délire c'est juste pour ça fait du
bien quoi de l'humour aussi avec
plusieurs one man show ou one woman show
notamment avec Thomas N'Gijol âge
Christelle Cholet ou encore Laura Laune
vous avez mis le paquet là cette année
parce qu'ils sont tous tellement
différents et c'est peut-être même à
chaque fois pas forcément la même cils
cible et bon Tom and Jijel je n'ai rien
vu si vous allez sur Internet vous
voulez voir la bande-annonce il y a rien
si vous voulez voir le spectacle bah
faut y aller la bande-annonce est basée
sur allez voir il veut garder ça c'est
Laura Laune c'est totalement trash c'est
interdit au moins de 16 ans donc
personne n'envoie ces jeunes de moins de
16 ans voir ce spectacle où il en prend
la responsabilité azat c'est vraiment
des des petites saynètes de vie qui sont
absolument hilarantes et Christelle
Chollet il y a aussi la chanson dans sa
dimension artistique il y a aussi la
femme de 50 ans c'est vraiment très
différent en fait c'est c'est de
l'humour oui mais on peut faire de
l'humour de tellement de façon et alors
en vue des Jeux olympiques de Paris 2024
vous avez aussi programmé une pièce
celle d'un sportif de saut à ce qui
c'est une histoire vraie elle se nomme
vol et dit vols j'aime bien les
histoires vraies surtout quand elles
sont totalement dingues c'est l'histoire
d'un jeune Anglais qui voulait
participer aux Jeux olympiques mais
c'est pas facile parce qu'il y a plein
de fédérations avec plein de
possibilités de d'y participer seulement
quand on est malin et qu'on veut
vraiment y participer on va créer sa
propre fédération et imaginez créer la
Fédération anglaise de soizky ça
n'existait pas donc il était le seul et
il a réussi à battre à faire le saut le
plus le minimum pour pouvoir participer
aux Jeux Olympiques ce qui fait que
quand il y a il a réellement participé
aux Jeux Olympiques à la fois on le voit
sur une petite télé remercie les acteurs
d'avoir raconté son histoire et c'était
tellement dingue que c'est lui qui a été
le plus applaudit en fait mais
franchement la pièce c'est pareil c'est
une comédie mais c'est une comédie qui
donne la banane alors justement je vous
propose de regarder un extrait on
continue d'en parler juste après je
m'appelle Michael Edwards mais tout le
monde m'appelle Eddy
le rêve que j'ai fait cette nuit j'ai dû
le faire environ
746 fois moi participant aux Jeux
olympiques d'hiver
les Jeux Olympiques c'est une blague
c'est une blague Michael on s'improvise
pas ce sportive de haut niveau
aucun participant britannique n'a été
référencé dans la catégorie soski aux
Jeux olympiques d'hiver aucun
ce qui veut dire que nous réussit en
saut en 71 mètres de long sous les
couleurs de la Grande-Bretagne tu verras
la torche olympique de près
alors elle a l'air formidable cette
histoire est-ce que ça vous donne envie
d'y aller en plateau
alors vous proposez également des
soirées spéciales cette année Florence
Kaman une soirée spéciale reggae et une
soirée spéciale latina je vous propose
qu'on en parle juste après mais avant
regarder un extrait pour qu'on puisse se
mettre dans l'ambiance
[Musique]
alors on a vu deux groupes se
succédaient le premier groupe au compe
secondo et combien boroka il promettent
d'enflammer la scène de la clé des
champs alors c'est pas seulement en fait
on a travaillé ensemble avec Frédéric
poletto qui est directeur de la clé des
champs qui est notre scène de musique
actuelle et qui entraîne en plein essor
et on a voulu ouvrir tout le bâtiment ça
veut dire que ça commencera
à la clé des champs avec le DJ
ortegadogo qui sera la demain soir donc
si vous voulez faire une profitez d'une
soirée endiablée ça commence demain à
20h30 au Théâtre Coluche parce que voilà
et puis après on fera la fête après vous
avoir présenté tous les spectacles et
donc le fameux Groupon Compay Segundo
dont je suis totalement fan dont j'ai
tous les disques et la découverte de ce
groupe latino hyper enviable et de
combien boruca et après le DJ on va
danser à la clé des champs ça va être
mais complètement fou et on le fera une
deuxième fois en mars avec la soirée
regga reggae avec Tiken Jah Fakoly et
d'autres petites surprises il y aura
encore trois autres groupes et ça sera
le la même ambiance on ouvre tout le
bâtiment le Conservatoire va faire des
initiations vont être voilà ce sera la
folie et bien merci beaucoup Florence
canin d'avoir répondu à nos questions
alors si vous êtes intéressé le théâtre
Coluche de plaisir fait sa soirée de
présentation demain soir à 20h30 vous
pourrez réserver vos places à partir du
mardi 20 juin 14h et sinon vous pouvez
toujours retrouver toute la
programmation sur le site internet qui
s'affiche en bas de votre écran